funny anytime someone calls bumblebee be
I think in Norman Reedus from Blade 2
I'm sorry man big whatever not the only
one right I don't know in any case let's
review bumblebee bumblebee
so bumblebee is a prequel or reboot or
reboot it takes place in the 80s
Cybertron has fallen so bumblebee has
come to earth that he poses as a
Volkswagen Beetle then Hailee Steinfeld
gets some double Decepticons are looking
for bumblebee bumblebees trying to stop
them and from there we have kind of an
Iron Giant et ish movie really enjoyable
movie too like the intro of this movie
is the Transformers movie you wanted to
see like all your life other than the
animated movie because it's it's rad and
it has the touch and the power but I
feel like the intro of this movie also
has the touch and the power I really
like Hailee Steinfeld's character she's
an outcast of course she's an outcast at
school and home she really doesn't feel
like she has a place anywhere unbeliev a
place here on earth so there's no wonder
these two get together I mean you know
hang out not get to get that would be
weird and Hailee Steinfeld did a great
job should be no surprise we almost as
good usually hit all the right notes she
was perfect casting for this movie John
Cena is also in it he's mister like Joe
Joe let's go get him not like not really
yo Joe God I'm correcting myself a lot
in this review he's not a GI Joe I have
to clarify for this one I'm just saying
he's mr. military like direct shoot
first ask questions later
you know the type in movies he's that
funny about John Cena when he was being
funny I thought it was really good it's
the scenes where he was trying to be
serious trying to be tough guy I was
like alright you're kind of overcooking
it yeah it's weird to say when that guy
was trying to be tough guy that's when
it was more unbelievable sounds weird
but it's how was I personally thought he
was better in the comedic moments he had
in the movie and if for nothing else I
just appreciate the fact that this movie
tried but wasn't Michael beggin alright
let's just print more money lore [ __ ]
the lore listen whatever let's print
more money it's not an all-out onslaught
of metal on metal is just bumblebee in
these two Decepticons looking for him
but when they were fighting it wasn't
like they were fighting and you see
other [ __ ] you're like why can't I see
them fight or when they were fighting
it's not like it was like in your face
like alright why can't I see him fight
when the movie wanted to show you the
Transformers fighting they showed it to
you when the movie wanted to be grounded
and down to earth it gave you that and
when the movie wanted to have heart and
give you the fields it gave you that I
will say I'm a little perplexed this
movie does come across as a reboot in
order for this movie to happen and
the other Transformers movies can't
really exist now for the groundwork this
sets up but other times in this movie
they reference the other Transformers
movies could call it a callback or a
throwback sure but it just it sends
mixed signals you're like is it a reboot
is it a remake or is it not it's kind of
like imagine Batman Begins doing alright
this is a reboot this is not linked to
the Tim Burton movies and you see Max
Schreck in there and they make a point
for him to look and sound like
Christopher Walken you'd be like you can
have is it a prequel it can't be yet
that says it is but that can't be I
suppose I just crave a little more
consistency when it comes to that stuff
this movie does have humor in which some
moments land better than other moments
and even the moments that didn't really
land for me it wasn't embarrassing it
wasn't like Michael Bay we're like oh
[ __ ] God it's fine they may swing and
miss but after they missed it's not like
they take the bat and shove it up their
own ass or anything like some of the
previous transformers movies out and
though this movie is quite a few steps
in a very good direction for live-action
Transformers movies it's still not like
a Transformers movie like the cartoon
was in the sense that it's not
transformers and concentrating on
transformers not transformers with
transformer problems and they'll
interact with the other transformers and
they go to transformers things the human
beings in the human world still very
much front and center I feel like the
sequel might go that direction out which
is why I call this app reboot cuz it
might be there and I think that would be
a good direction to go for the
Transformers movies but Woolsey I'll say
bumblebee was a great time no alcohol
required best of the live-action
Transformers movies thus far it's also
not two and a half hours long minimum
that helps alright so bumblebee have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you wanna see more
click right here to see more
[Music]